yeah sorry welcome to this video playing
en booly booly booly booly from poland
and we have them tirage the gimmick
variation of the terrors yeah my
knowledge is really limited the only
thing that I know is on Gavin oh it's um
I watched this video series by John
Watson on the ICC is done a video series
on the French and they recommended the
this variation for black but this is
already am the sky is an IM yeah okay
he's really overlook this move or to
have I overlooked some counter trick
otherwise he just really overlooked this
district it's very well know from the
French actually in the advanced wise for
instance okay but he's got a strong
night on e5 and need to be M be cautious
f7 s so hanging and b7 si
hmm yeah this isn't so easy the case of
the other guy blundering but not
instantly losing yeah f6 queen edge
fibers I could I could play that
actually at the end time I'm also
winning i'm also winning on everyone
maybe maybe this isn't so bad actually I
can take pt5 this was silly okay well
even this isn't too bad but it's not
thinking about this too much maybe a gap
of age six is the problem you're only
calculated up to Queen takes deform
Bishop age of six it's not a big issue
push-up 86 I think I can castle Bishop f
897 getting it back
I'm done i'ma pull up at the end of
course this is somewhat silly after
after all this fit but anyway it's upon
covering e6 and I control the default
yeah I I need to activate the night if I
get this night to some active post
should be a ride night let's say a 596
something you can still play rock do you
wanna ok let's drop back OOP do you want
Quinn yet I'm tending 9265
yeah Quincy 694 this is the ideal way to
continue
night Cara cannot be bad down rapid
Queenie six maybe queen or twin c6
actually why not it's not 97 is not a
fork
Queenie five I can play Knight f3
yeah design looks weird or just a form
yeah II for mp4 and Knight f3 and Quincy
one this should be over Jack may be here
jicama cannot go to f1
b 5 b form looks good getting rid of the
night so that i can play Queen to see
one he's got one check but this is this
is the only thing
I see no defense win with this the
easiest on Quincy one it's got one check
but it is it is just a check here and
I'm fine Queen g1 f1 mate yeah it's no
lo defense I don't see a defense Quincy
one mate can give a check I go to a
seven it's got no check and King h3
there's queen of one mate no way to
cover that
white resign now ya well what what a
strange opening he overlooked this
really simple trigger but somehow this
wasn't so clear in fact he could have
taken here funny because of this so yeah
yeah cool he overlooked that but it was
still not so clear have sex is the best
move okay here I thought he would take
on b5 but it's still quite quite okay
for black the thing is if you look at
this I know this looks weird with the
king but it's all protected and I've got
25 coming up Bishop d6 got a very good
position against the isolated pawn that
he's got very bad pieces for the
isolated Queens pawn he lacks the light
squared Bishop in particular and 25b
should be six is actually attacking yeah
pretty good and this seems seems quite
quite nice for black just a pawn up and
the computer agrees yeah somewhat
strange to to have such a high rated
player overlooked 95 but it was in fact
not so bad 9f 7s it's really a funny
trick here alright thanks for watching